big shake-up for Disney pluses upcoming
Lizzie McGuire reboots et has learned
that Terry Minsky the creator of the
original show and showrunner of the new
series has left the project after
filming two episodes he doesn't sound so
good when he puts it that way guess I'll
be going now a Disney spokesperson tells
et quote fans have a sentimental
attachment to Lizzie McGuire and high
expectations for a new series after
filming two episodes we concluded that
we need to move in a different creative
direction and are putting a new lens on
the series production is currently on
hold as the show looks for a new
showrunner no word on what this means
for the first two episodes they filmed
but we have learned a lot about the
series over the past few months you know
we were having a lot of fun and it it
just feels very surreal Hillary has been
sharing all sorts of pics to Instagram
we also got this clip when the series
announced the return of Adam Lamberg aka
Gordo wait wait Bam's not complete
without me Gordo's back this is what
dreams are made see why don't you to me
[Music]
in November Hillary herself spilled new
deets to et she has gained a lot of
confidence and she has a really cool
career and you know she's still I think
she's still gonna be faced with
challenging things we're in middle
school those challenging things seemed
funny and simple but relatable at the
time and I think now in your 30s it's
gonna be the same way but it's like
slightly heavier slightly bigger things
to deal with like she doesn't have kids
yet and she you know she there's some
surprises in the first episode that I
also don't want to give away but I think
it's really gonna be fun to go on on the
journey with her at 30 and you know it's
the same Lizzie but she's an adult
and and I think for me that's a little
challenging shooting because I have that
muscle memory of that like awkward
frantic kind of teenager and so making
choices ran like flame of eight she
wouldn't say that she's 30 she can't do
that now like it's it's definitely fun
and a little challenging and also so
familiar at the same time animated
Lizzie does she have an updated look
she's gonna she's gonna stay the same
yeah which i think is is the right thing
to do right it's like that pink top it's
so iconic and like platform flip-flops
yeah those like rocket dog flip-flops I
don't know if anyone knows those but
yeah she has an epic return and I'm I'm
so excited for everyone to I think she's
really gonna be a lot of the comic
relief in the show
[Music]